so how are you doing today sir
yeah i'm pretty good actually yeah
pretty good in my car
right exactly um i just want to point
out that you think that you know jamie
having a successful movie career
uh could afford to be somewhere other
than his car but
no i'm i'm teasing you know it's a nice
car
confusing i've been asking this of
everyone i've been talking to recently
the next few questions um is there a tv
series you would love to guest star on
um succession it's just so good like
it's just mind
alteringly good acting and oh it's just
insane
uh what movie do you think you've seen
the most
oh probably willy wonka is that because
of the family or because of you
because of um well probably me you know
originally obviously and then uh with
only recently probably in the last 12
months
started introducing uh the older two
kids
to it um and they're probably even a
little bit young for it to be on
us but i just want to get into their
sort of consciousness as early as i can
listen i don't blame you um is there a
tv series that you have watched
all the way through more than once i'm
going to say
no the answer is no but i've been very
close to my we talk
you're so spoiled now because it's
always just the next thing and the next
thing and this is great and this is
great so you've always got something new
to look forward to
but now and again you hit a little bit
of a rut don't you and you're like i
don't know i don't know
and i with with toyed with the idea of
starting um
uh of starting sopranos again toyed with
the idea of starting uh the wire again
and um yeah might be that
that might they're probably the two that
we've toyed with i mean i've probably
seen every friends episode more than
once so does that kind
i don't know no no that counts
right um what have you been binge
watching uh
during the pandemic i mean it feels so
long ago now tiger king doesn't it
really it feels like a lifetime ago but
i guess i was on that train
um with every every single person in the
world here on netflix
um uh wow what else have we watched
um i've been watching a lot of uh
god that's terrible isn't it i don't
even know i mean we're so tired once we
put the kids to bed
that we're like you know we can usually
squeeze out like one episode of
something and then
like there's not even time for binge
it's like it's like watch one episode
and go
oh my god it's nine o'clock we have to
go to bed that's
kind of our life um but um i tell you
there's a show that i don't know
how you can get it in the stage but it's
a beautiful show called mum
um and it's leslie manville is the lead
in it who is obviously an
absolute legend and it's just so
wonderful it's just
beautifully um very funny very british i
guess
but it's very um it's it's really worth
finding if you can so we definitely
binged out when it was
on the done two series um
jumping into your acting career for a
second uh
when was the last time you remember
being super
nervous about getting ready to film
something
and why every single job i do
um because if you lose that i think
you're screwed
i mean you should be sort of terrified
you know i'm you know i i
i heard michael kane talk about that
years ago about like
you know how the terror of and you know
uh of of of doing it over hearing the
word action
it's terrifying and just knowing you're
about to
commit something to celluloid for uh for
the rest
of time and all these people are um
are working hard and this guy's got this
really tricky
focus pool to do and the camera
movement's really tricky and it's kind
of
you know if you [ __ ] it up it's uh it's
it affects all these people and
i'm very aware of that and i carry that
a lot i think and
you know but i think it's right it's
it's sort of nervous energy but it's an
excited energy you know i just
finished shooting this movie with uh
kenneth branagh
directing and you know he's such a
legend and i'm i i'm such a fan of his
and i've always wanted to work with him
and
so day one on that i mean it's the last
thing i shot we just we just rapped
um day one on that i was like is kenneth
brenna really
about to watch me act and be happy with
it you know it's like
how's this gonna go but it was like the
most joyous experience ever
oh we're gonna get to belfast in a
little bit um
what's funny is i interviewed kenneth
earlier this year and he was telling me
about
how he was writing something personal
and we were going to
shoot it later this year and he wasn't
specific with me but now i know what it
is and you know
everything else um what's the most
important thing you need
in your trailer
um probably like some sort of like
i i'm obsessed with this stuff called
biltong
which is like a sort of african but you
can get it ever or not it's basically
like a
dried out meat i mean it's it's like a
fancier version of jerky i guess uh you
guys are jerky but jerky is quite dry i
find and it's
it's a little bit uh i i'm one of those
people i need to
i need to i pretty much i'm only happy
if i'm eating
um so i'm i'm i try to like make sure my
trailer's stocked with like
stuff that's like filling and high in
protein and they'll keep me
um going a bit so um probably that or
this crazy when we were doing wild
mountain time
emily got me hooked on this like this
uh i don't know it's like an energy
drink i think it was
we called it our acting juice it was
like we felt that we got this stage
where we sort of couldn't work without
it
it was this crazy like fizzy um
energy drink that like dwayne johnson
had got her into
when they did jungle cruise or something
it's kind of kind of crazy uh
thing so um i might need that from now
on
got it um well what you didn't realize
it's called jolts uh cola
it's just caffeine and sugar that stuff
no it's not that stuff that stuff is
rocket fuel right exactly listen
anything that dwayne is drinking it's
obviously super healthy
exactly will i look like him do you
think i think you're going to land on
your feet
you're going to be okay right um
what props or costumes have you taken
home from set
i don't do that i've not really done
that i don't think no
i tell you um the only one that sort of
comes to mind
i remember um and yeah no i
i the the um my like paramedic jacket
and synchronic
um i they gave me that at the end as a
gift
um because i think i'd voiced a lot of
you know while we were shooting i've
done a lot of um
you know i love this i really love this
jacket i would wear this jacket you know
socially so they um they gave me that as
a gift at the end but usually i don't
ask for stuff or take stuff
it's interesting i totally would be
taking everything
and having a storage unit uh filled with
crap
um but that's me i think if i was on
like you know
something really iconic you know like
star wars or something i'd probably be
trying to take some sort of prop that
like
everyone would know about and have it in
a case of my you know
shelf or something but i haven't done
that yet uh
you many years ago before you were an
actor um you used to do modeling work
for like hugo boss and
calvin klein in a bunch of places um can
you
watch the movie zoolander and have fun
with it
um you've seen zoolander right do you of
course have seen jaylander um
i i i love such a brilliant movie it's
so
obviously so funny um what is crazy
about it
is that like well i'll tell you what i
was really lucky because i never did um
runway i've never done a catwalk in my
life
i i i i kind of hated modeling to be
honest so
um i could just the bike take my my
photograph taken which i
again i really don't didn't enjoy don't
enjoy
but the whole like trying to look cool
walking up and down the thing forget
about it like i
just couldn't do that so i literally
never did it in my life
but uh one time i went to try to do it
in like milan or something when i was
like 20
and i sort of got laughed out of the
room i don't have a great walk
anyway and i probably wasn't really tall
enough for
runway stuff anyway um but i met a lot
of it's the only time really because i
was sort of lucky
i did photographic stuff um it was
one of the only times i was around a lot
of other male models was when i went to
lake milan to try to do these
get these shows and um zoolander isn't
that far off
some of the guys i'm not i'm literally
serious like
some of those guys were were that was
kind of their vibe they weren't like it
wasn't like it was obviously heightened
in the movie but like
i mean i've actually seen the clip but
there's some it's on youtube of the
thing that inspired like ben stiller
um of these guys who are like
supermodels back in the
90s or whatever and they're they're not
quite doing the thing at the gas station
with anything but they're they're
they're so dumb and um uh
great inspiration for for a great comedy
but um i've seen
guys like that i'm very glad i'm not
involved in that anymore
yeah that's an industry that will never
uh pass me an invite
so um i can only ask about it and
live vicariously through other people
moving on to the next thing i saw an
instagram that you
had built recently a lego set uh i
i am a big fan of lego and i think a lot
of people are big fans of lego
especially during the pandemic when
you're trapped at home
uh what are did you have fun building
that thing
i'm gonna blow your mind steve um
today it's half term so my kids are off
school
um we went to legoland today
right i mean literally today um
and you know it's a great setup there
the uk legoland i mean they
it's very they're wiping down everything
constantly you're
constantly hand sanitized everyone's
wearing a mask it was it was
great you know um and obviously they
did it's not fool you know they don't
allow they only allow certain people
but um it was uh it stressed me out some
of some of the
some of the things that are built with
lego and i'm sure the huge things
they're they're not all lego inside i'm
sure but um
it gave me sort of flashbacks to having
um to to build these things for the kids
because
they they honestly think like they bring
it home and they they want to play with
it immediately and they
they expect me uh i sort of guess i give
off this impression that i can sort of
do everything fix
everything and you know i'm just some
like oracle of like you know
anything they need done or any
information they need they think
my wife and i can answer and can provide
which obviously isn't the case
and i mean i had to build this bus thing
this like fun bus
i mean it took me all day and it really
took me all day it took me
seven or eight hours of the day building
this thing they played with it for
25 minutes and you know it's i don't
think it's been touched since
yeah that that sounds like kids yeah
excited you know um
one of the things though there's no good
thing about the pandemic
because obviously it's terrible the one
thing i think is a positive though for
famous people
is you can actually go out in public and
no one really knows who you are
so were you able to experience like lego
land
because you're wearing a mask like could
you actually experience it where people
are like
leaving you alone um
right up until we left i swear like
nothing
got totally got away with it um i was
wearing like a cap and a mask and it was
sunny very sunny today so i had glasses
sunglasses on some of the time
and then right at the end we were sort
of like before we got in the car making
the girls go to go to the bathroom one
more time before we get in the car
and i stand outside bathroom i noticed a
couple of stuff a couple of girls and
stuff
notice and giggle and blah blah and um
they didn't make a scene
like they were a little bit chatty on
the way out but they you sort of can't
ask for photograph really in this time
which is um
you know fortunate unfortunate whatever
way you want to look at it but um
that was it and we've been there for
like four hours and nobody
said anything so um it was pretty good
although i did have one thing
i was buying i was in uh like a record
store a few weeks ago buying like rap
gifts actually for for belfast and um
uh i was wearing my mask obviously and i
was paying and the guy behind the
counter
was like he recognized me from my voice
which is really
really weird and he'd been like binging
the fall at the moment because it's just
come on the netflix
here so he was like oh hold on a second
jamie dornan and i was like
uh yeah wow this is great i really
thought i'd know him but he recognized
me in this mask and he was like it's
your voice it's your voice
okay i also think though if you've been
binging something
and you've been staring at like your
eyes and then you're right
you know when you hear the voice you see
the eyes you're like wait a minute
you know that's true that's right yep um
so jumping into why i actually get to
talk to you today so
i thought synchronic was a fantastic
original sci-fi movie
um i am a huge fan of this film um
what was it like talk a little bit about
um reading that script for the first
time
because it it's [ __ ] cool yeah
well it is that it is [ __ ] cool and
it's to be honest it was unexpected
for me um it it affected me emotionally
in a way that i wasn't expecting a
sci-fi script to affect me
often you know i'm not a huge sci-fi guy
i have to admit but like often with
sci-fi movies i can feel
fairly disconnected from the characters
that i'm and i'm watching for
two hours i'm a bit like i don't really
care what happens to these people
they're sort of like fairly
two-dimensional and
they haven't given me any information
about them that's gonna like
attach me to them more than they're like
good-looking actors like running around
with
laser guns so this
grabbed me in a different kind of way
you know and i felt very connected to
the
to the to the story and to to the the
plight that these
both these guys are going through you
know and it was very heavy and
and you know relatable and but also had
this other real fantastical mad
aspect to it and you know got me at the
end i cried at the end you know and i
really
wasn't expecting to be so emotionally
moved by it and
um you know i'd seen the endless that
that that aaron and justin had done them
i just thought these guys are really
exciting and then they're
treading new ground and they're they're
paving away for a different type of
sci-fi movie i i
felt like and i still feel like so
it was a cool opportunity i think and
and and and
also with with uh with
i would think i was attached first but
then there's already a lot of talk about
anthony mackie who um
i you know as a fan of so it was just
like one of those things where
um you know shooting in new orleans
which is is a
is a city that i really wanted to get to
know you know i'd been there for two
nights
before and never really stayed and
uh wanted to get the opportunity to know
it better so it was like there's this
perfect sort of marriage of
aspects that um that that made me say
yes very quickly
yeah i obviously don't want to do
spoilers but i will say that one of the
really smart things about this script
is using the history of new orleans
as a major story point in the sci-fi
of the film and being able to use it in
a very cost effective way
yes yes yes totally true and i mean they
they really i mean it's you know like
you say often with with movies that um
the city itself becomes a character in
the movie but i mean
none more so than this you know it is um
so beautiful but also i mean they really
showed new orleans for like every aspect
that that city can offer you know and
the sort of shiny glitzy aspect of it
and also the really
darn and dirty desolate um
parts of the city of which we shot many
of them but
also this that city has such a soul you
know the people have such a soul and uh
i think we did a you know they did an
amazing job at capturing that you know
and
um again for you know not they didn't
have a load of money to to play with
obviously in
this movie and none of us are getting
you know paid well i guess we're usually
paid
and um i just think they made it
look so elevated beyond what they had
with with
the way they shot it you know no
completely and it's
it's just a testament to the power of
storytelling
because it's clear that this is not
being made for some crazy budget
but yet they managed to tell this great
story
on a very limited budget and um you know
but what what when you're getting when
you're given a script like this like
synchronic
how much are the directors and people
telling you about the full
story arc and what it is and how much
are people saying to you
hey read the script we don't really want
to tell you too much
yeah a bit of both really you know at
the end of the day it comes down to
um the script and and i think it's kind
of good to re you know i'll
you know i'm fortunate enough that i get
sent a lot of stuff and uh usually
they'll be
uh along with the script they'll be my
agent saying
if it's someone that i don't know about
particularly well like if i don't know a
lot about
his or her stuff there'll be a bit of a
thing about
but like these guys are really exciting
this woman's really exciting you need to
you should read this or prioritize this
script above those other two percent
whatever it is you know
so there's usually you have an idea of
what you're in for and and
on what the appetite of your your your
team is
around the filmmaker but essentially
i have to respond to the script and with
synchronic i just responded to
the script and then it was a bonus of
them meeting justin and aaron and and
hearing their vision and their
enthusiasm and their um
yeah just their their the the sort of
joy that they seem to have of making
films you know they're they're really
like
you know there's they're they're so
thirsty for it you know they they are
like
ambitious yes but like they're so
excited i'm so excited that they're
getting to make these movies that they
write themselves that
you know that that are aaron is that
it's a dp on them and
you know that often they act in their
movies you know they're um
not this time but everything they've
done since before they've acted in i
think they're doing something at the
moment that they're acting in
so they just like it's so joyful to be
around these guys you just love making
movies you know this is very infectious
you know
um so i'd like the script anyway and
then i met those boys and
you know over uh skype or this before
zoom anybody knew what zoom was i think
before the pandemic
um and uh then it was just
you know their enthusiasm was so
infectious and it always just seemed
like such an easy decision
it's so interesting because scripts
are the the best someone said this to me
recently during an interview and it's so
true
scripts are a terrible bl they're
they're the a terrible blueprint for
what the cinematic experience is
actually going to be like
but it's the only thing you have um yes
so what if you don't mind sharing is
there like a script that you read
that you're like oh this is not gonna
work and then it ended up being
like fantastic or a script that you
thought was
wow and then it just did not you know
what i mean like an example of how the
script can really not reflect the final
product
yeah it's it's you know um that's why
it's often really good to
um if there's a lot in there that you do
um i don't know cling on to there's a
lot in there that you do like about a
script it's always worth
you know hearing discovering what else
you can find out about
how they want it to look you know annoy
when you get a script there's so
it's very rare to get a script that
doesn't have a lookbook attached and
all like a deck showing you like shot
ideas and
an unreal like very detailed description
of the the characters and biographies
and
a more in-depth idea of why they're
telling the story and then the
director's vision
so usually that accompanies the script
these days you know which is really
really helpful
because um you can read a script one way
and then
you see what their visual landscape is
like for and you're like oh
wow that's really not how i saw it you
know
and that's actually maybe better than
how i saw it or that's like way off and
actually don't
if they want it to look like that which
if you're seeing it at that stage that's
why they want to look at it
that's how they want it to look then you
know it maybe doesn't work out so much
i've had scripts i've read
where i've kind of really uh liked it um
and visually on the screen directions
are so um
uh dense and uh
detailed and really beautiful and you
find yourself getting like
oh my god this is gonna look so amazing
the way the description of when they
open that door and see that world for
the first time it's crazy
and then you go actually hold on a
minute the dialogue's terrible
and at the end of the day you have to
say those words
and um as actors i'm sure i speak
forever and we've all been in situations
where you're saying words that you
don't love and they don't feel that
comfortable and they don't come out easy
and um
and so if you've had those experiences
before
you have to make sure that the words on
the page are words you want to say i
don't care how beautiful the description
is you've got to be able the words have
got to be great
so you've sort of ended up casting those
scripts aside
because of that because at the end of
the day
they can ham it up talking about how
beautiful the shot's going to be and
ever but you still have to stand there
and say that dialogue and if that
dialogue's not good enough it's not
going to work
jumping into wild mountain um since
no one will have seen the movie yet and
i hate asking the generic thing but can
you for people
that want to know about the movie how
have you been describing it i've
probably said this during press before
for movies and maybe not totally
believed it but it is
kind of like a movie like you haven't
seen before it is like
um or it's like a movie from another
time and i think in the most
beautiful way and and really poignant
way and really
suitable for the time we're living in
way it is like an old
school romance it is
almost fable-esque fairy tale-esque in
in the sort of
high high sort of heightened the romance
of it is
and there are these you know centers
around these two um
fairly odd people you know my character
anthony reilly
and emily blunt's character rosemary
muldoon who have grown up on
their farmers and they've grown up uh
the neighboring farms in in rural
ireland and um there has been this
crazy connection more so from one side
for their whole
lives and they haven't been able to do
anything about it um
and we're you're basically getting to uh
glimpse into the minds of these two very
complicated people who
who ultimately you really want to be
together as
as as as difficult as that concept seems
at times because of the way they behave
but i it's you know
i guess it's john patrick shanley who is
a
titan of our industry um and
he has a particular tone i think this is
almost going back to his earlier films
like
moon struck in in its tone which at the
time was its own
thing you know when you watch moonstruck
now and it kind of lives in its own sort
of world and i
i hope wild mountain time sort of finds
that similar kind of place where
people will get really sort of like
enraptured by it if they buy into it
they'll be like
they'll they'll be really into it um so
uh
yeah but but but i don't think it's like
anything else anyone's gonna see
uh this year next year um i watched it
last night
and i will say that you are 100 correct
it is not like something it is an old
school romance um
you play a character that is very
emotionally
closed off um and uh what is that like
you know because obviously that that
isn't you you know um
so what is that like i mean it was a
huge challenge for me but actually
weirdly
you know i guess if i mean it kind of is
set modern day but i think you'll agree
with me that
it almost feels like it's set in another
time um
if you know let's say it is today
anthony's on the spectrum
he is and you know and i'm not saying
that's a negative thing anything but he
would be classified as someone who's on
the spectrum now he's
someone who's finds um dealing with his
own emotions other people's emotions
very difficult
you know and he is someone who is
uh not quite world ready
i would say he's he's kind of a bit
um he's sort of being
disconnected from the world for most of
his life and
as a result has a lot of social anxiety
and is is a difficult person in his own
skin
and i feel like there's a lot
you know i find that as much as you know
i
you can often give off this idea that
you're
confident or gregarious or have stories
to tell
or have have a sort of um
you know a
likeness of yourself whatever it is all
these things that you try to
emit um often inside you're you're
terrified
and you you feel like you really can't
um expose certain aspects of yourself
and
there's a lot of anthony that i i felt
that i had with within me and a lot of
his
strangeness and his quirkiness and
i think a lot of people do carry that
within them and
maybe don't let the world see it a lot
of the time and uh
so um it was nice for me i feel to
be able to maybe through anthony's show
a lot of
my own sort of uh all this old
quirkiness weirdness that i carry within
my own bones
um and it's just a joy to play him i
really i mean it was such an
incredible experience making that movie
you know with that cast and with john
and it was it was a
mad brilliant uh experience i have
literally like 15 questions about that
film and i have one minute left with you
so i'm
gone uh we'll probably we'll talk again
when the movie's coming out i will just
say for everyone
who's going to watch it uh make sure you
have a guinness in hand
yeah just make sure you have a guinness
in hand whenever you're watching any
movie
right uh my only beef with the film is
that there's a guinness
bottle that's in the film and i just
really wanted them to be drinking from
the tap
um it was a whole thing but let's uh
let's move on because i'm basically out
of time
but i really have to talk about belfast
and kenneth branagh
um because there's not much information
known about it
what what are you allowed to say about
what the film is about and who you play
probably not that much um i
you know you can look into what you will
that like ken
is originally from belfast and this is a
story called belfast so
you know i probably can't say too much
more than that but it's um
you know as he said to you when you
interviewed him i presume for tenet
um it's actually it was for artemis
spell
oh sorry this file okay but it's deeply
personal it's deeply personal story
uh for ken as he's already divulged to
you
um so yeah it's it's a personal story
about
you know that involving ken i guess is
all i can say but i had an
absolute dream making that movie i mean
i literally rapped
two weeks ago and and you know i don't
think it's a secret that judy dench is
in it and kieran hines and katrina balf
and
all these amazing people again similar
to wild mountain time just felt so lucky
and chronic and i i
feel like everything i've done recently
i've been surrounded by these incredible
actors and support players who have
we've all just been this sort of magical
team with people i look up to and
it's it's i feel very lucky i i know it
takes place in the late 60s
and i think it's basically about a boy
growing up in the 60s and it's
essentially kenneth from what i can
understand
i mean listen you know i don't know i
i know you can't say anything um listen
i gotta stop there but i really mean it
that um
everyone should watch synchronic
especially if you want to see original
sci-fi
um and support original sci-fi and um
we'll definitely talk again for wild
mountain because
of you know i want to talk about
christopher walken and the insane
scenery
and it was like picturesque i mean
there's a million things to talk about
yeah we'll definitely do that um yeah
on that note congrats on everything and
thank you for indulging all my stupid
questions at the beginning
thanks steve always a pleasure man